hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Matt Welch
we're doing ask a libertarian 2012 to
celebrate the paperback publication of
our 2011 book the Declaration of
Independence that has a new forward
please pre-order it at your bookstore
online next question from Franklin
Carter via email
what's the libertarian solution to crony
capitalism and if it is possible to
abolish crony capitalism
how do people prevent it from coming
back well you're never gonna abolish
crony capitalism but the best method for
limiting it is by limiting government
this is counterintuitive to a lot of
people so slow it down
think about the record number of
lobbyists lobbying in Washington DC when
did that happen
well that's happened under the Barack
Obama administration which came into
office saying we're gonna reduce the
power of lobbyists well they did that at
the same time while spending record
amounts of money and writing huge bits
of legislation in the form of the
Affordable Care Act in the dodd-frank
bill which kicks a lot of things to
regulators and when you do that you are
inviting industry to come in and write
their own legislation the more
regulation you have the more crony
capitalism you'll have and the more
deregulation you have the less one
example that we talked about at great
length in the book is the deregulation
of the airline industry for four decades
the airline industry from its inception
in the late 30s through the early 70s
was the same for Airlines it was crony
capitalism perfectly managed they got to
determine who entered the market who you
know flew this route between these two
cities with the help of the government
well when the government caught out of
that business suddenly those big guys
had to compete they didn't like it
everyone else did especially at
including the consumers if you want to
help crony capitalism limit the amount
of big government activity and you know
the one thing that we can do without
minimizing the way special interest
politics works by creating a populace
and a voting electorate that is
interested and you know totally
frustrated by crony capitalism we can
reduce it we can get rid of politicians
who consistently vote against broad
interests in favor of narrow special
interests and that's part of what we try
to do in the book moving away from the
sort of stuff to actual capitalism to
free-market decentralized power
and innovation is the way to reduce this
going forward ask a libertarian 2.0 keep
those questions coming we'll be here all
day see you soon